welcome to deconstructing chatbots I am
priyanka regalia and in this episode we
are going to explore how to integrate
dialogue flow with Google assistant once
you build your agent on dialogue flow
you can use the one-click integration to
connect to various platforms such as
Google assistant slack
facebook Messenger Twitter and more
today we are going to look at
integrating tie log flow with actions
and guma actions and Google is a
platform where you can create software
to extend the functionality of Google
assistant by integrating dialogue flow
with actions in Google you can reach
over 500 million devices that support
Google assistant such as smart speakers
phones cars TVs or watches it's
considered the same appointment
scheduler chat pod that we built in the
previous episode and worked through the
integration click on integrations we are
going to explore Google assistant
integration today so let's just click
that in the pop-up window we define
explicit invocation what intent do we
want to trigger when a user says ok
Google talked to smart scheduler smart
scheduler here is our trigger name we
will see where to set it up in just a
little bit in our case welcome intent is
the perfect spot for the user to land on
so we will just stick to that let's say
a user says ok Google asks smart
scheduler to set an appointment for 5:00
p.m. tomorrow
that is an implicit invocation so in
this case we could invoke our scheduled
appointment intent directly since we
know exactly what the user wants to do
if we want the service to be only
available for signed-in users then you
can check the sign in required button in
our case it's just a demo so we will
just keep it open to everybody we are
then going to click on test first since
we just developed our app let's see how
it functions or if it functions
correctly
[Music]
okay that looks great now let's explore
the manage assistant app button this
provides us to set up the invocation
name to our chat bot we called it smart
scheduler this is also the place to
select male or female voice for your
assistant going back to overview we have
already built our application and it's
ready to test when you are ready for
deployment make sure you have selected
the countries you want to deploy in and
the surfaces you want your actions to
run on you will have to provide a
description for your application sample
invocations for example here we've added
talk to smart scheduler you can add more
it also requires two images one small
and one large contact details and
privacy information fill up all those
things once you have done all that and
feel comfortable to push the application
to production use the release option to
submit to production of course here we
have not finished the overviewed items
so we don't have the ability to submit
your production yet you can also enable
the launched in beta to open it up for
up to 200 users with alpha release you
can enable your action for up to 20
users without submitting for review
alright so today we used our appointment
scheduler chat bot that we built in the
previous episode and integrated it with
actions on Google don't miss the next
episode of deconstructing chat BOTS
because we are going to make our
appointment scheduler a little bit
smarter
[Music]